die schweiz ein land in dem man gerne
lebt ein land in dem eigentlich alles
funktioniert viele menschen teilen im
hintergrund dazu bei
[Musik]
canet carli fährt mit dem postauto in
die hintersten täler des tessins dennis
schöne betreuten der region die kranke
kinder branche siegenthaler ist
kranführer im berner oberland und meine
batterien arbeitet in der uhrenindustrie
und hat sich nach der kündigung
selbständig gemacht
wie leben diese menschen wofür setzen
sie sich ein
und was beschäftigt sie vier menschen
und ihr alter ein tag im leben der
schweiz
cordula tessin es ist halb fünf
der 26-jährige kahnert hat frühdienst er
ist mit einer tessinerin verheiratet
meine frau ist nicht da gestern abend
ist sie zu ihren eltern dazu wird bis
samstagmorgen dort bleiben sie wohnen
nicht so weit von uns entfernt in den
oberen berger
das mag er nicht
es weckt erinnerungen ans waisenhaus in
somalia in dem er aufgewachsen ist
[Musik]
zur gleichen zeit auf der anderen seite
der alten in thun
der 36-jährige rasche ist ebenfalls früh
auf das ist garantiert
tankstellen alles sonst im haushalt
macht seine frau und die zwei kinder
schlafen noch kann etwas sein postauto
innsbrucker im hintersten winkel des
online ohne tals holen
im radio läuft die landeshymne letztes
jahr wurde der somalia eingebürgert
ich vertrete beide länder aber ich habe
meine kindheit in somalia verbracht bis
und ich wohne seit zehn jahren hier
vielleicht werde ich hier mehrere jahre
verbringen
20 aber ich habe 15 jahre in somalia
verbracht diese sind wertvolle ich weiß
nicht warum das ist ein hirsch naja das
ist ein hirsch
ein ganzes rudel
[Musik]
es ist 6 im berner oberland roche ist im
werkhof angekommen
seit zwei jahren arbeitet er für diese
baufirma endlich hat er seinen platz
gefunden
er ist immer früher hier müsste eine
branche war ein schlechter schüler und
hat seine lehre als zimmermann nur knapp
geschafft nachher hat er als handlanger
gearbeitet bis er durch einen
glücklichen zufall eine ausbildung als
kranführer machen konnte
[Musik]
belm und in der nähe von biel es ist
halb sieben
die 46 jährige dennis lebt mit ihrem
partner und ihren zwei kindern hier am
morgen ist nicht ihre bevorzugte
tageszeit ihre tochter jasmin geht in
die letzte klasse der oberstufe die zwei
hauptthemen am morgen sind wie in den
meisten familien mit teenagern die
ordnung und das handy und hamburg
gewertet wieder eingestellt
wenn sie jüngere schaut sich dann auf
uns zu auch in die 2 und wenn ich lust
habe ich starte ich mache ja nach wochen
haben die frühen morgen nachlegen koffer
die männer in der familie stehen früher
auf sohn simon macht eine schreinerlehre
und partner stefan ist offen monteur
denise arbeitet bei der kinder spitex
die ausgebildete kinderkrankenschwester
kann sich die zeit relativ frei
einteilen
[Musik]
um die gleiche zeit im abgelegenen
propos im neuenburger jura weil ist
covering ich trage nicht unbedingt make
up wenn ich weiß dass ich den ganzen tag
in der werkstatt bin wenn ich niemanden
sehen und nirgendwo hingehen dann gebe
ich mir nicht diese mühe aber ansonsten
trage ich gerade genug um ein wenig
schwach aus zu sehen
sie lebt mit ihrem freund seit drei
jahren in diesem haus und arbeitet zu
hause wenn ich um sechs uhr aufstehen
kann ich um halb sieben einmal einen
tisch sein
ich verliere keine zeit keine fahrt kein
parken
aus all diesen gründen ist es sehr sehr
bequem finde ich so ganz freiwillig hat
mal das allerdings nicht gewählt sie hat
15 jahre lang in der uhrenindustrie
gearbeitet wurde aber vor einem jahr
wegen einer restrukturierung entlassen
jetzt versucht sie es als selbstständige
[Musik]
das ist ein ziemlich massive ring
da steht jetzt darauf im hip hop stil
diese schrift berlin new style habe ich
noch nie gemacht
es ist cool
340 kilometer entfernt um die gleiche
zeit
langsam füllt sich im uns ein ohne tabus
seit zwei jahren ist cannes hat bei der
post dem gelernten lastwagenfahrer macht
es spaß sein postauto durch die engen
straßen des tals zu steuern
ich halte mich für einen glückspilz
für mich ist es nicht nur eine arbeit
es ist mehr die schweiz hat eines der
dichtesten netze der welt es gibt fast
12.000 postauto haltestellen und mit
2300 fahrzeugen befördert die post rund
155 millionen fahrgäste pro jahr
ankunft in lugano es ist sechs uhr 57
die fahrgäste sind fast immer dieselben
leute die zur arbeit und zur schule
gehen als kanada in die schweiz kam
wurde er von valor nach chiasso verlegt
das war vor zehn jahren mittlerweile hat
er sich gut integriert aber ein
buschauffeur aus somalia
das war schon ungewohnt hier ich weiß
nicht wie sie reagiert haben
aber sie haben mir viele fragen gestellt
aber nicht angefangen habe war ich komme
wie solchen style.com bin diese sachen
halt sie hatten positiv reagiert sagen
wir mal
rosies kran ist 35 meter hoch es lohnt
sich vor dem aufstieg zu überlegen ob
man etwas vergessen hat seine baustelle
liegt bei oberried am brienzersee
es ist 8
hier sage ich mit der band im studio
auch ich sagen wie ihr was was machen
eigentlich sache wahrscheinlich zogen
und nixe branche hat seine berufung
gefunden
inzwischen ist auch seine familie
mein geschmack torlos
[Musik]
zurück am bielersee dennis hat ihren
ersten termin um 9 zeit um sich vorher
noch um den haushalt zu kümmern
die aargauerin ist ursprünglich wegen
dem vater ihrer kinder in den kanton
bern gezogen
vor zwölf jahren hat sie sich aber von
ihm getrennt allerdings und das ist
nicht immer lustig machen abgehalten und
sieben jahre war sie allein bis das
schicksal sie zu einem alten bekannten
zurück geführt hat ursprünglich kam
heraus wo er ist im gleichen dorf
sevigny und eigentlich kollegen gut die
kollegen von mir geschickt im internet
und ich bin jude gestört und danach
streben ob es noch möglich erinnere mich
und dann hat mich getroffen und dann das
ist so entstanden
jedes sechste paar in der schweiz lernt
sich mittlerweile über das internet
kennen
die dunkelziffer ist natürlich groß
nicht immer einfach wenn er neuer mann
ins haus kommt wie hat das funktioniert
stefan ist quasi wie papier sagte kind
obwohl sie sporadisch mit ihrem vater
kontakten bayerischen karate ist wieder
auf dem weg nach bruder
es ist halb neun er hat seine frau über
eine asyl organisation kennengelernt
seit vier jahren sind sie verheiratet
nie hätte er gedacht dass er einmal im
unsern unita landen würde
meine reise hat in somalia begonnen
ich bin durch viele länder gereist kenia
uganda sudan libyen dann habe ich die
migrations route genommen und bin nach
frankreich gegangen und von dort in die
schweiz
mein ziel war es in ein sicheres land
auszuwandern wo ich mich integrieren und
ruhig sein kann
im tal fühle ich mich gut hier gibt es
weniger probleme
[Musik]
er war fast noch ein kind als aus
mogadischu geflüchtet ist
letztes jahr ist erstmals wieder in
seine heimat zurückgekehrt
[Musik]
die schule liegt am meer 1100 metern
höhe
es ist ganz anders letztes jahr bin ich
nach somalia gegangen und nach nur zwei
wochen vermisste ich die berge das brot
für diesen laden wir laden von bruder
es ist wichtig dass wir das brot bringen
wir lassen es hier wenn der besitzer
kommt wird es sehen
das ist ein dienst den wir anbieten
wir tragen auch brot und zeitung los um
dieselbe zeit im neuenburger jura
mal arbeitet still vor sich hin ihre
einzige begleitung ist das radio
als selbstständige sind wir unsere
schlimmsten feinde denn wir üben druck
auf uns selbst aus obwohl es nicht
unbedingt notwendig ist so lange als
arbeit gibt und wir in bewegung sind
haben wir keine zeit für stress es geht
uns gut
aber plötzlich gibt es momente da
beginnt die paranoia und fängt an sich
mit voller geschwindigkeit zu drehen und
dann muss man etwas tun um sie
aufzuhalten
man muss eine heiße dusche nehmen oder
stricken oder in den garten gehen um
unkraut zu jäten und dann geht es von
selbst vorbei es ist kurz vor neun
denise ist auf dem weg zu ihrem ersten
patienten
sie arbeitet seit über zehn jahren für
die kinder spitex wenn immer möglich
betreut sie die kranken kinder über
längere zeit jetzt schön romantisch mit
rind und und sie strahlt ja danke ich
merke dass harmonie stimmt dass ich sind
sehr schön im moment einfach aus
dankbarkeit spüren was du machst aber es
ist nicht immer einfach
levin hat die lungenkrankheit cystische
fibrose und muss täglich zweimal
inhalieren
das findet er meistens nicht so toll
[Musik]
die woche sind allerdings neue pläne und
mit demut und es gibt etwas besser gar
zum phase muss man weniger gut
aber wichtig ist einfach verklungen dass
die immer durchschlagen
mainz blieb psychische fibrose ist eine
erbkrankheit lebens mutter wusste dass
ein gewisses risiko besteht dass ja kein
ist eigentlich nicht auch am pillersee
branche macht pause
nicht abrufen wenn man jetzt hier
hauptstadt in die pause hoffen wir haben
nicht vergessen nummer 15 minuten pause
so jetzt als auch länger geht es ist
nervig minuten länger zwei minuten puls
oder gewitter branche gilt das mode und
überaus liebenswürdiger und
hilfsbereiter kumpel
er lässt sein leben so wie sie sind fast
zwei drittel aller arbeitskräfte auf den
schweizer baustellen sind ausländer
damit hat er überhaupt kein problem
russland aber die sich natürlich schon
seit jahren
derzeit tragen hat man schon mit dabei
die dortigen arbeiter wo ja endlich der
hölle die arbeit fort während der andere
preise kommen auch paarweise seite gilt
darsteller vergnügt für die natürlich
den ich vielleicht haut nur mascara
plötzlich das zimmer bis 30
das machen ja sorgen muss man auch wir
haben ein gesicht heutige zeit ausgeht
so schnell plötzlich ja
daher gleich dazu branche stammt aus
schwierigen ärmlichen
familienverhältnissen und hat erstmals
in seinem leben eine stabile situation
kein wunder hat er manchmal angst
kart fährt wieder los obwohl er seinen
job liebt sein traum wäre eigentlich ein
anderer gewesen
ich habe alte maschinenbauingenieur
werden aber bis heute habe ich es nicht
geschafft
nun hatte aber ein neues ziel seine
letztjährige reise nach somalia hat ihn
inspiriert er will etwas für sein
heimatland tun
ich bin somalia und ich will meine
herkunft nicht vergessen hier in der
schweiz fühle ich mich gut ich arbeite
ich verdiene geld
ich habe eine schöne frau ein schönes
haus und ich habe keine sorgen
der rest könnte ich vergessen ich könnte
mir die anderen schöne orte reisen um
mich zu erholen
ich gehe nach somalia meinem volk zu
helfen
er hat einen kleinen verein gegründet
und sammelt geld
in belm und nutzten es eine kleine pause
um das mittagessen vorzubereiten
ihr dienst sid jeden tag anders aus
durchschnittlich arbeitet sie 60 prozent
und bringt gut alles aneinander vorbei
und alles verbinden mit liter schaffen
langsam wird es auch einfacher
normalerweise kommt nur noch jasmin zum
mittagessen heim
[Musik]
dennis muss nach b die kinder spitex in
ihrer region hat 17 mitarbeiterinnen
gesamtschweizerisch sind es etwa 600 die
sich um rund 2000 kinder kümmern kinder
spitex dienste sind durch die
grundversicherung oder die iv gedeckt
wie bei den erwachsenen auch leonard ist
elf monate alt und wird tagsüber in
einem hort betreut
dennis muss ihm seine medikamente über
eine magensonde geben und dafür will die
hauptleitung keine verantwortung
übernehmen
sie müsste dann eine beurteilung alles
gut ist das halt sehr schwer machen
darum machen ließ dennis hat jeden tag
mit kranken kindern zu tun
nicht in allen fällen gibt es ein happy
end wie ein video das ist macht
natürlich noch mal anders mit ein
und was aber sauer ist relativiert
mariquita ganz schlimme sache sieht dass
man muss sagen dass das dominante haie
oder die probleme um ihre hand
das ist eigentlich gar nicht
leonard gibt es im moment recht gut
[Musik]
es ist kurz vor zwölf am brienzersee
entsteht eine noble eigentums und
feriensiedlung mit eigenem hafen
jedes jahr werden in der schweiz etwa
50.000 neue wohnungen gebaut obwohl das
bevölkerungswachstum zurück geht schätzt
die uno dass wir im jahr 2050 die 10
millionen grenze knacken werden
es ist meine idee war dass laster
befreien gescheitert
was hat er denn es macht einfach bogen
von einem acker gefunden worden
es geht gegen mittag zu aber für uns ist
keine pause in sicht
[Musik]
das ist nicht noch planlos
die 27
glücklicherweise hat er sich vorher zwei
sandwiches gekauft
[Musik]
branche fühlt sich extrem wohl in der
schweiz also vc große politik muss das
richtige staat greife daher wenn ja muss
sturm selbst
[Musik]
denise hat auf halb eins nach hause
geschafft jasmin hat gerade mit der
lehrstellensuche bekommen nutzer aus
noch schlug hause klima trat
mechanikerin und dann kommen die neue
kita geschnuppert
ich hoffe das ist richtig dass ich
besser machen und das ist handwerklich
sollte aber immer spannend war das ist
wichtigste wichtig dass die auch dass
man in der familie alles diskutieren
kann ein schönes äußerte sich der fco
mit dem ehemaligen und sorge und das
mittel sind und dass wir sie
unterstützen das wüsste dass die familie
das ist schön
[Musik]
nach dienstschluss ist carat unterwegs
für seinen verein
diesen hat er gegründet nachdem ein arzt
und alter freund aus dem waisenhaus in
gebeten hatte medikamente nach somalia
zu schicken
eines der großen probleme in somalia ist
immer noch die beschneidung von frauen
die leute beginnen zu verstehen
es gibt einen mentalitätswandel die
eltern vor allem die mütter haben ihre
töchter verstümmelt damit sie
gesellschaftlich akzeptiert werden und
damit männer sie heiraten heute wollen
männer keine verstümmelten frauen mir
also sind die eltern jetzt gezwungen die
töchter nicht mehr zu verstimmen weil
sie sonst keine man mehr finden
das trifft vielleicht für urbane gebiete
zu aber in somalia werden immer noch 98
prozent der jungen frauen beschnitten
dass es mehr als überall sonst auf der
welt
das medikament soll kokain lindert
schmerzen und entzündungen die
apothekerin isabella sollberger hat sich
bereit erklärt kalla das medikament zum
selbstkostenpreis zu verkaufen
diesmal wie letztes mal gehe ich
persönlich ich werde alles dokumentieren
und ich werde da bleiben bis die letzte
packung verteilt ist oder zumindest die
hälfte
ich werde alles dokumentieren bevor wir
die bestellung machen würde ich gerne
wissen wie viele sie brauchen es wäre
dumm ihnen medikamente zu liefern diese
nicht nutzen werden soll
jacobi
es wäre nicht ideal verschiedene
medikamente mitzubringen
man muss nicht unnötige bedürfnisse
herstellen
man muss auf präzise fragen reagieren
wir müssen ja auch nicht 1000 liefern
wenn sie nur 500 brauchen uns brauchen
mehr als 500 ich sage 500 weil wir nur
so viel bezahlen können
auch mal hat einen termin sie muss den
siegelring in der show abliefern
ohne auto geht gar nichts aber man
möchte um keinen preis hier weg in diese
region bin ich geboren aufgewachsen und
zur schule gegangen
hier habe ich alle meine freunde die
familie sie sind auch alle in dieser
ecke zwischen dem walde ruhe und möchte
alle menschen die ich liebe
darum bin ich geblieben so ganz hatte
sich noch nicht an ihre
selbstständigkeit gewöhnt es gibt immer
ein wenig stress ob man alles richtig
gemacht hat man nicht vergessen hat
es gehört dazu aber es ist kein
negativer stress
ich kann es einfach kaum erwarten ihre
rängen zu hören die schmuckdesignerin
olivier jean reno hat ihr atelier zu
hause sie hat schon ein paar
schmuckstücke beim isle bestellt und ist
für diese eine wichtige auftraggeberin
da du denn hin weil ist erleichtert sie
hofft auf weitere aufträge denn die
konkurrenz schläft nicht graveure hat es
wegen der uhrenindustrie in der gegend
mehr als genug
allein im kanton neuenburg wurden in der
branche in den letzten zwei jahren fast
500 stellen abgebaut
wir gehören zu einer generation die
vielleicht alle zehn jahre arbeitslos
wird
es ist aber nicht so schlimm für mich
war die arbeitslosigkeit auch ein
sprungbrett
ich glaube nicht dass ich ohne
arbeitslosigkeit selbstständig geworden
wäre
[Musik]
zurück im tessin hat ist auf dem weg zur
moschee vier moscheen gibt es im kanton
235 in der ganzen schweiz meine religion
hat mich immer geführt
jeder hat seine eigene ist christ zum
beispiel obst eine religion aus und ich
liebe meine religion
daher gehe ich in die moschee für das
islamische freitags gebiet wie ihr sehen
könnt hat die moschee kein minarett
es ist nicht obligatorisch für unsere
religion so lange ich sie frei ausüben
kann bin ich zufrieden
ich verlange nicht viel im
industriegebiet von giubiasco beten
regelmäßig etwa 2 100 muslime aus der
region
karat findet es unangenehm dass jede
moschee momentan im verdacht steht eine
terrorzelle zu sein
ich kenne die leute nicht ich weiß nur
dass sie muslime sind
sie kommen aus der ganzen welt es hat
schweizer italiener pakistan somalia
eritrea äthiopien algerien marokkaner
tunesier muslime aus dem balkan und aus
der türkei
das sind ihre staatsangehörigkeit habe
ich der religion ist der islam
darum sind sie da sie sind nicht da um
leute zu treffen
sie wollen nur ihre religion ausüben
nicht quatschen oder etwas anderes
ungefähr 350.000 über 15-jährige muslime
leben in der schweiz
das ist knapp fünf prozent der
bevölkerung und weniger als halb so viel
wie in umfragen jeweils geschätzt wird
es ist 4 dennis besucht die zehnjährige
emily
[Musik]
mit sex musste das mädchen erstmals
operiert werden weil es zwei ungleich
lange beine hat das heißt man hat mit
dem stellen der das knochenwachstum in
dem sind so angelegt dass der kreis bei
jennys hilfe beim waschen und schaut
dass es keine infektionen gibt
[Musik]
die beiden kennen sich schon seit der
ersten operation
[Musik]
amelie ist verhältnismäßig selbstständig
im gegensatz zu anderen kleinen
patienten für familie und war mit
größeren abdeckung pension uhr morgens
zum kind aufnehmen und alle ecken und
und im rollstuhl setzen oder was auch
immer
er weiß dass ließen unterstützung die
meisten händler aber noch andere sind
und die leute sowieso schon immer zu
kurz
ich denke es ist für die betroffenen
eltern sehr schwierig und darum sind sie
dankbar
bei mir kommen es ist halb fünf
für mich jetzt viel aber
zehn stunden lang war er auf seinem kran
eine toilette hat er da oben natürlich
nicht als kranführer muss man sich zu
helfen wissen
[Musik]
canet ist früh aufgestanden endlich zu
hause angekommen will er nur noch eins
schlafen da ich bin müde
das ist mein mittag und abendessen und
ich muss so schnell wie möglich ins bett
morgen ist der neue arbeitstag auf
wiedersehen es ist halt sex als partner
sam ist von der arbeit zurück er ist
maler zeit für ein feierabendbier
die beiden sind ein eingespieltes team
[Musik]
wir haben uns 2002 bei der gay pride in
neuchatel kennengelernt
schlimmer noch es war ein
one-night-stand der schief gelaufen ist
anscheinend denn jetzt sind wir was 16
jahre zusammen ja und wir haben uns seit
16 jahren nicht mehr verlassen
es war ein schönes treffen völlig
unerwartet
ja wirklich gcg pride party und lerne
die liebe des lebens kennen
nein es ist cool kinderkriegen war für
sie nie ein thema es war von anfang an
ziemlich klar dass wir keine kinder
wollten
wenn wir mal ein kind wollen kümmern wir
uns um die kinder der anderen
wir haben zusammen neun nichten und ein
neffe
auch roche herz nach hause geschafft vor
einem halben jahr ist er mit seiner
familie nach thun in diese
genossenschaft siedlung gezogen etwa
fünf prozent aller wohnungen in der
schweiz sind genossenschaftswohnungen
daraus frau nicht arbeitet und der kein
spitzenverdiener ist ist die familie auf
günstigen wohnraum angewiesen
[Musik]
musst du leicht
branche versucht seinen kindern alles zu
geben was er selbst vermisst hat vor
allem geborgenheit und zeit
leistungsdruck möchte ihnen eigentlich
lieber ersparen was die generation wird
es das ipad auch am bielersee gibt es
nachts denise partner stefan hat gekocht
dieses ziel wäre einmal am tag alle
zusammen an den tisch zu kriegen aber
immer schaffen sie es nicht ausgeflogen
da ist das ist unglaublich ich für jedes
mal mehr wachsen
[Musik]
angefangen haben sie bereits mit
loslassen und schmieden ferienpläne
nicht unbedingt die nordlichter lage das
ist so schon so als fußnote träumen ob
das mit und ohne kindern stattfinden
definiert
[Musik]
es wird nacht in der schweiz in thun
sind die kinder im bett
nicole und orange spielen oft noch uno
zusammen
wie gesagt noch schön wirtschaftsleben
gedankt sie verbringen
nicht jedes hobby und riesige mengen
spruch sei noch gar nicht so viel wie
haben sie sich kennengelernt
das internet ja seit dieser nach
abrechnung des berlin erwartet also mir
ist so langweilig ökologisch ist das
auch eine flut und wechseln vieles
findet christdemokrat profilbild und
fotografierte folgen von erste station
beim sprung gemacht dass miss minogue
als größtes verlauf gaben
[Musik]
auch mein und sam haben ihr abend ritual
sie treffen sich meistens in der küche
wir kochen gerne zusammen wir erzählen
uns von unserem tag das ist cool
ja das ist ein kleiner besondere moment
zwischen uns beiden und da gerne essen
verbringen die viel zeit in der küche
nachts ihr zu sein
wir beide zusammen dass es cool die
umgebung die ruhe ein bisschen musik
hören und niemand steht uns auf den
füßen herum
das ist großartig morgen stehen sie
wieder auf und mit ihnen acht millionen
andere menschen in der schweiz jeder mit
seinem alltag mit seinen wünschen und
träumen um mit seiner ganz persönlichen
geschichte
[Musik]